megan fox teases her latest business
venture and only fans account and after
seeing her latest picks with kourtney
kardashian we can see why just you know
living our best lives and
the ladies are living their best lives
in these new sexy behind-the-scenes
polaroid pics from their skim's photo
shoot the gal pals sizzle in skin-baring
looks as they pose in intimate positions
and when we say intimate we're not
exaggerating first the girls kneel on a
marble floor face to face or should we
say cheek to cheek the sexy meter rises
for this one quartz straddling meg on a
toilet tons out and buns out then in the
last shot the two lay on the floor as
megan's hand touches courtney's leg so
now that your pulse is probably racing
meg has an important question should we
start and only fans i'm just like living
life and
whatever happens happens whatever daddy
says something tells us meg's probably
twisting our arm but hey you never know
we just honestly don't know yet but it's
no surprise megan in court have gotten
close thanks to their rocker boos
machine gun kelly and travis barker it's
a beautiful thing mgk and megan attended
the lovebirds italian wedding back in
may and they're not too far from tying
the knot themselves love is probably the
biggest project i've ever worked on yeah
source tells et the pair is in the final
stages of planning their big day quote
megan and mgk are pretty much done
wedding planning they're both totally on
the same page which has made things easy
for them but megan is definitely pulling
everything together and has the final
say on what goes and what doesn't how is
that all coming together i know
obviously you've been looking for the
right location for the right gothic vibe
how's it going
um i'm gonna leave that kind of like a a
present for the world to unwrap when it
happens clearly mgk isn't letting
anything spill but our source says the
two want their ceremony to be dark sexy
very punk rock and glam their
relationship is very intense dark
romantic and sexy and that's how they
want their wedding celebration to be
they're planning things together as one
and looking forward to starting a new
chapter together
[Music]
you